[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the new hogwarts legacy game
that was announced on the playstation
youtube channel last week
now since the game has been announced
many fans have been asking themselves
what's it all about is it canon are we
going to see the characters
that we grew up watching the trailer
which boasts
an impressive 10 million views in its
first week reveals very little about the
game
other than that we will be a student
attending hogwarts in the late
1800s late 1800s is a pretty broad time
frame
and this terminology would generally be
used to describe the time period
between 1870 and 1899 which leaves 29
years of events
that could potentially coincide with a
new game in this video
i'm going to be exploring some of the
events of the wizarding world
during the 1870s 1880s and 1890s
and speculating on some of the events
that we may see transpire
or hear about in the game before we get
started let's get one thing clear
avalanche software and portkey games who
are creating the game
have been very open about their
dedication to keeping the game authentic
to the original franchise what's
authentic means
at least from my perspective is that
they're going to preserve canon
only time will be able to dictate
whether they follow up with that
statement or not
but i really hope they do adrian ropp
head of story at avalanche software
who are bringing us the game alongside
portkey games had this to say
when the first book came out i became an
instant fan this
is a labor of love and the real magic
comes from the dedication and
imagination
of a team who wants nothing less than to
make this an authentic
and compelling wizarding world game this
cements the fact that portkey and
avalanche
are taking their task very seriously and
will be attempting to approach the
wizarding world
from a new perspective while preserving
the elements of the wizarding world that
we've already been exposed to
without further ado let's get started
and begin by taking a look at the events
of the late 1800s
events that very well may coincide with
the new game 1872
bolandi's exquisite crystallized
pineapple was first introduced to the
world
okay i know what you're thinking
pineapple hear me out
it just so happens that balandi's was
the brand of crystallized pineapple
that tom riddle gave to horace slughorn
on the day that cyclone provided him
with information
on creating horcraxes while i'm sure
riddle would have been able to convince
seghorn to tell him
pineapple or not it certainly helped his
case 1875
gripping charms are discovered
discovered in 1875
the gripping charm was a charm that
revolutionized quidditch and the design
of the quaffle
as it allowed chasers to hold throw and
catch the ball with one hand
eliminating the need for straps or
finger holes
1875 the decree for the reasonable
restriction
of underage sorcery is passed by the
ministry of magic
the decree of the reasonable restriction
of underage sorcery
was a bylaw of the ministry of magic
that banned the use of underage magic
used outside of school
this decree is of particular importance
to the harry potter storyline
as harry was purportedly in violation of
this decree before being exonerated
when he used the patronus charm on
dementors in the order of the phoenix
this by law is enforced by the improper
use of magic office
inside of the ministry of magic and you
might remember harry receiving a certain
letter
from a miss mafalda hopkirk dear mr
potter
we have received intelligence that you
perform the patronus charm at 23 minutes
past nine this evening
in a muggle-inhabited area and in the
presence of a muggle
1876 the peeves versus rancorous carp
incident in the year 1876 there was an
incident
involving peeves the poltergeist and
then hogwarts caretaker
rancorous carp rancorous carp preceded
both
polion pringle and argus filch and was
caretaker for many many years
i expect that we will see him in the
game in some capacity
rancorus in an effort to trap and
capture peaves
set up an elaborate trap however when
his trap failed
it led to peeves acquiring several
dangerous weapons resulting in an
evacuation of the school
whether this will make it into the game
or not is unclear but it was certainly
eventful
and it all occurred right at hogwarts
school 1877
the 393rd quidditch world cup the
quidditch world cup can be described as
follows
a source of vehement disagreements a
security risk for all who attend it and
a frequent focus for unrest and protest
the quidditch world cup is
simultaneously the most exhilarating
sporting event on earth and a logistical
nightmare for the host nation
in 1877 the 393rd quidditch world cup
was held in rin desert kazakhstan
this particular world cup went down in
history as the tournament that nobody
remembers
for reasons unknown no one in the
wizarding world could remember a single
match of the whole tournament
after it had ended there are several
theories for why
no one could remember the first being
that mass memory charms were cast by the
goblin liberation front
and another speculating that there may
have been a breakout of
cerebrumus spatigroid a fungus that
causes memory loss and
confusion so that's the 1870s
but what about the 1880s the 1880s were
actually the years
that many notable figures in harry
potter law were born
which is why i find it particularly
interesting that hogwarts legacy
happens to be set in the late 1800s in
the year 1880
none other than voldemort's grandfather
who was also called
tom riddle very original i know was born
tom riddle and his wife mary hailed from
little hangleton
and they had one son also named tom
their son tom is the same tom that was
bewitched by marapi gaunt
and the same tom that was the father of
lord voldemort
just one year later in the year 1881
hogwarts headmaster albus dumbledore was
born
albus's parents percival and kendra
dumbledore
and at the time of albus birth the
family lived in mold on the world
albus was their first child in the same
year 1881
famous pureblood wizard and lifelong
friend of albus dumbledore alphaius doge
was born
doge was a powerful wizard and during
the first wizarding war
joined the order of the phoenix in an
effort to help oppose lord voldemort and
the death eaters
fast forward to the year 1883 and there
were even more notable births
first mary riddle was born the
grandmother of lord voldemort
and shortly after that in the same year
none other than gaelic grindelwald was
born
in 1884 the dumbledores had their second
child
aberforth and in 1885 they had their
third child
ariana the 1880s were truly important
years
in wizarding history as so many witches
and wizards good and bad
can be closely linked to this particular
time i find it really interesting that
within five years
voldemort's grandparents albus zambda
and his siblings
and gaelic grindelwald were all born but
as the 1890s closely followed
a lot of important things happened then
as well in 1892
albus dumbledore began studying at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry and was sorted into gryffindor
house
in 1895 his brother aberforth began
attending the school as well
and though it isn't confirmed it's
suspected that he was also in gryffindor
sometime between these two dates
grindelwald also would have begun his
studies
however he was a student of durmstrang
institute
not hogwarts fast forward to the year
and dumbledore was graduating from
hogwarts a total star
he was head boy winner of the barnabas
finkley prize for exceptional spell
casting
and the list goes on but perhaps the
most notable event of the 1890s
and perhaps the 19th century as a whole
was when geleck grindelwald and albus
dumbledore
met the two boys met in godric's hollow
and it was there that their short-lived
relationship
went sour when during an argument a
three-way jewel broke out between albus
ab fourth and grindelwald that resulted
in the death of dumbledore's sister
anyway that's a rough summary of some
important canon events that occurred
during the late 19th century
whether we see or hear of any of this
happening is up to avalanche and portkey
to decide
but i expect that we will at least catch
a whiff and that's it for this video
what events of the late 19th century
surprised you
what important events did i miss do you
think that hogwarts legacy is going to
feature or mention
any of this let me know down in the
comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you